han pasado más de 200 horas desde el
terremoto pero en antioquía este joven
de 13 años que fue rescatado de la edad
Esperanza a los socorristas
y encaramaras la rescatada fue una joven
de 17 años
sin embargo la realidad es otra en la
mayoría de las zonas donde tras diez
días de trabajo no hay expectativas de
hallar sobrevivientes es por ello que
empiezan las demoliciones controladas a
gran escala los restos de los edificios
no son habitables miles de afectados
viven en las calles no tenemos vida
Estoy extremadamente preocupado por mis
hijos los envié fuera de la ciudad me
caliento con leña en un balde duermo a
la intemperie Esto no es vida
la comida de escasea los medicamentos y
el agua potable también hay temor por la
situación sanitaria para los sirios del
panorama no es más alentador de hecho en
las ciudades fronterizas del lado Turco
donde viven miles de refugiados sirios
hay un creciente sentimiento de rechazo
que las autoridades buscan evitar
en el noroeste de Siria abundan los
edificios que apenas se mantienen en pie
y los escombros también abunda el miedo
por encontrar numerosos restos humanos
cuando sean removidos
sabemos que el número de muertos excede
los 6000 en Siria Esperamos que este
número no aumente demasiado pero por lo
que estamos viendo y escuchando la
devastación del terremoto no nos da
esperanza de que esto acabe pronto
la ayuda que llega al país árabe se
queda corta y es lenta en aparecer en
las zonas Rebeldes bloqueadas por el
gobierno de bachar al azar Naciones
Unidas ha alertado sobre posibles brotes
de cólera sarampión y sarna y reiteró su
llamado a las autoridades y a los grupos
Rebeldes a permitir el paso a todas las
zonas para evitar una catástrofe mayor